Rio is a close friend of mine as well
he's a he's a he's a mentor to me but
I've said it to him before I think John
Terry was the best center half in
premier league history his near post
defending I think both feet his
leadership ability to get goals as well
just a raw
Defender his impact on Chelsea the clean
sheets the record that you guys have in
the Premier League 15 goals conceded
player of the year I just think he was
just a prop proper Center back you know
Center half and you're looking at in
that time where there was so many good
Defenders Rio vidit and PUO and PK all
these guys John Terry was at the one
constant amongst all of them when you're
looking at the world team of the years
you're looking at UF for team of the
years John Terry was that was that that
one you know what I mean I think it's a
very 1 a 1B these are my two best center
halfes for me in the premier league
history but he was just that guy man so
hey Rio yes